I rescued George he was 2 years old. He's not just a friend
He's family, don't move a muscle. Are you crazy?
Don't move very
Funny you and I laughing at your joke new guy you know about
He cry you can get up now and check your diaper come on
Your message about George you okay?
George
It's okay
Isn't mirrors he considerably bigger
No, he's definitely bigger need to find someone who knows exactly what the hell this thing is I found her no
That's a lie technically she found us
What's happening to my friend? Are you familiar with genetic editing?
Changes will be incredibly unpredictable
(Increased strength George speed agility)
Bills and chains that came run Where's George. I need to see him. He is dangerous
I think it's time for me to turn the man
We've created the next chapter in natural selection project rampage works
Another one of your little science experiments running around. What do you mean?
Of course the wolf flies
This time we throw everything we can at these things and get people the hell out of that city, let's go save the world
That's a big arm don't fight it. You know there are other ways of dealing with people right I?
Do know that yeah, but that's not fun
George okay ready to do this buddy you
You